so we went to a
woman psychic of psychic dog psychic in
marina del rey well that's not a scam
hello everyone hola mis amigos you're
listening to oh my god
you know george is oh i'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
george
george lopez oh my god omg omg
so when cbd is too mild and dispensary
thc is too crazy you got to try diet
smoke delta hthc gummies legal in most
states you can get them shipped to your
door
go dietsmoke.com use the promo code
omghi for 20 uh omg hi for 20 off that's
omghi at dietsmoke.com
for 20 off i'm gonna tell you something
right now
of all the stuff that i've tried
diet smoke
is the best it's like it's non-invasive
you don't feel like you're too loud or
you don't feel like everybody's looking
at you
nothing about atlanta
[ __ ] people wait a minute i said
where's he from i looked at it i was
like [ __ ] atlanta said atlanta
why isn't he running atlanta
you talk to guys back there like friends
back there and yeah
outside of one sister is in north
carolina everybody's still in atlanta
and we go there i have a kid now so
we're there quite a bit
whereas normally it'd be there once or
twice a year now like four times a year
um but yeah i still got
a bunch of friends um although a bunch
of them moved like
and you know understandably uh if you've
spent time in atlanta
but what is that though like what is
that
whole thing like the boating and the
whole
like trying to make it harder for people
or some of the things that go on over
there politically oh it's terrible
contrary to the rest of the country well
uh in a second i mean well you know the
voters rights and yeah but that i mean
that's cool that's happening in every
kind of purple or red state you know and
uh i mean what's going on in texas is
way worse but um but yeah it's bad in
georgia too but you know they have that
you know atlanta's that pocket of blue
and savannah too or like little pockets
of blue but it's
i mean even growing up there
it's more so now but even like the
feeling of if you just drive 35 minutes
in any direction outside of atlanta i
mean you just you're like oh wow
wow you know
there was a
baseball player if you guys want to know
who it is i'll tell you
that was uh
he's latino and african-american and in
the 60s he was playing minor league
baseball in the south
and his roommate
was like a dude that was always like
scoring chicks and drinking in the room
you know the guys doubled up and he said
man i got to get out of here you know
and he went for a walk and got pulled
over and almost really almost got shot
and killed by the police is in georgia
yeah yeah
and he was like it he goes man it opened
my eyes like i was just walking yeah and
they come up on me and they're like let
me see your hands the lights are in his
face and he's like i i you know i'm fr
but you know i'm here playing baseball
i'm over there you know they come over
and rousted them and it still happens
look at you know uh uh you know um
the guy was just murdered in uh uh was
in atlanta but you know like
that one yeah yeah and uh
trayvon martin you know to go get some
[ __ ] candy and
you know i i don't have any fun
unfortunately for myself and in my naive
sheltered life i don't have fun wait a
minute
you were in vietnam
you know i don't have fond memories uh
after right after vietnam they sent me
to
fort stewart georgia
and
i was brought up here in l.a
and i had never experienced segregation
back then in 1969 they still had
white's only you know signs whites only
really yeah 69 1969 they still had signs
up there that's probably the best place
to eat and well i don't know i couldn't
go in
you know and i'm just sitting there
saying
my gunner took the first gunner that i
had got hit got hit in the back
and he was black
and i said we couldn't walk down the
streets together and go get something to
eat or use restrooms or stuff like that
if
you were here with me you know he was
already out of the army back
and i just it was so bad
and that was so i just stood on base on
base you know
cool i requested send me back to vietnam
i'd rather go back and fight than be
here with it's not the way i was brought
up and i was uncomfortable and where is
fort stewart
uh outside of south carolina he was
trying to make it about 50 miles
my memory served me correctly it's about
50 miles out of savannah right and i
never made it to savannah yeah
savannah's cool it's interesting it's
looked beautiful the place looks
beautiful it's a trip it's it's i mean
listen it's beautiful the united states
it's beautiful and places to go see but
i mean i think you know i'm a member of
a few clubs
and you know those clubs were created so
that a certain group of people aren't
allowed to be in there yeah even to this
day like this girl
friars club uh yeah
savage club
different than costco
you're talking about the the the
flagship lounge at american airlines
yeah you can't get it
uh uh i don't know why they make the
american card uh express card black
that's not gonna help
you uh
did you make a white card that the uh
but um
in
in growing up like that it's like
where'd you grow up i grew up here in
the san fernando valley
but even amongst ourselves in our own
community there's what did i tell
somebody that
the mother wants
the father wants it to be a boy
the mother wants it to be healthy and
the grandparents wanted to be
light-skinned
[Laughter]
i mean i was i was dark
like darker growing up and even darker
in the summer and
and
[ __ ] kids would be like my mom
doesn't want me to to play with you
because you're dark
yeah i mean i had look i i was uh jewish
and blatantly jewish i mean i'm bald now
and have been for a while but uh
i mean i had due fro and i was
you know i mean that was as foreign as
anything there were there were way more
um
black kids probably not so many latinos
but more probably more latinos and black
kids
where i was growing up than jewish you
know um
you know that was
white southern baptist you know uh kind
of
faux
civil you know polite faux pas who's
their enemy who what are they i mean if
we're all worshipping somebody who's
who's their enemy people that look
progressive liberals you know um
i think it's and and
you know but
for a lot of people
it was so foreign like they're they're
uh but anybody's putting out the right
word they're they're on they're they're
not comfortable and they they uh
um just like they would see uh black
people or latino people go oh my you
know my property values are gonna go
down and they're gonna bring you know
crime and uh whatever i think
it there wasn't that with uh
with me but it was uh it was just
you know foreign and weird and uh and uh
i mean i have old old old bits about
you know growing up jewish in the south
and um
and it's different now i mean it is a
atlanta's vastly different it's much
more
uh
cosmopolitan and global and
international um but man when i was a
kid it was it was weird
yeah
it's um
things have changed a lot and not oh it
changed
not too much longer after i left yeah we
got rid of gil okay now let everybody
come on
everybody's safe now but it's all about
you you were holding them i remember
them talking about uh a black black man
and a white female yeah i mean that's a
georgia felony right there yeah that
stays called a georgia felony my
grandmother um
i was in san fernando california and
there was a
african-american man dressed very
naturally tired with a hat
and he was holding hands with a white
woman this probably had to be
um 68 or 69
and my grandmother looks at them and
looks at me and goes
that's the other thing it's the it's
like the older generation like you
should know like i have i had
uh my uh my uh
an uncle and an aunt
that
you know got really upset when a black
family moved uh and this is in
westchester uh or no it was in the it
was in the bronx or westeros but um i'm
like of all the people
like you
you should know you should know better
and
it's yeah it's a bomb yeah uh um you're
special i saw it
it's very good oh thank you that's very
very good really good congratulations
thanks thank you and uh um
what venue is that you live in you live
in brooklyn yeah that's a venue in
brooklyn right it is yeah that um that's
where i was when i was uh getting shows
together to get ready to go on the road
and i had to cancel my tour
unfortunately so i like scrambled to put
that
set you know to tape it and just did it
all kind of uh
myself and um
i mean i didn't operate the cameras
obviously well it's well done very well
well thanks uh and i'm disturbing myself
and it's gonna be on my website and
that's you know it's a whole new thing
but uh
yeah that's one of the venues i would
play it's called the bell house in
gowanus um which is a great great venue
they have music it's a it's a theater no
it's like a music or a comedy club and
um you know we put the chairs down
there's some you know for for comedy and
some things we'll have uh chairs but
yeah otherwise they move the chairs out
about how many people like maybe
seven hundred thousand
uh no i think if you
if you took off if you crammed everybody
in there took the chairs out it's
probably
i'm gonna say 556. 600 maybe maybe not
even maybe four shot bigger here it
looks bigger
well that's the magic of it is a magical
thing yeah so so when you call tricks
george so so i know i'm learning
when you put that set together
was it
from a to z it appears like it's like it
was
like it's really well done like you took
the time to
to really
put it out there right it's an hour runs
at almost an hour yeah yeah it's
well i mean here's how i i've
approached the last uh
three specials or this i want to ask you
without seeming like i because i'm in
the business like seeing like like i
don't but it's but it's really to me
would you like some tips george i would
yeah i think all of these i'm not gonna
tell which ones and you'll become i'll
put them maybe you'll become successful
but i mean just the way that it it was
just all really good man and i mean and
i mean the vaccination anti-vaxx thing
in this in the beginning is brilliant
yeah this is brilliant thanks i i
uh
i mean
as as you know i mean the the one of the
most important parts of putting a set
together that a lot of people who don't
do stand-up don't ever think about but
is sequencing i mean that's a really
key
part and
and you know the way i get uh
all my
sets together tours is you know
especially when i'm starting from
scratch
uh
i start and i go around brooklyn there's
so many clubs and i bike to everything
it's all i'm like centrally located i
have my bike
and i do
these shows called shooting this
shooting the [ __ ] seeing what sticks and
i go when i just have ideas and things
on
you know no paper and it starts at uh i
usually start at like union hall in park
slope it's 99 seats in a basement
crammed together you know and i just wow
i tape everything and i and i'll have
special guests so i'm not doing you know
at least people are getting real legit
jokes and um
and then as i accrue the material and i
go oh this works that didn't work and
you know i listen and i kind of edit and
uh figure stuff out and then
i go to bigger venues
still kind of do the same thing and then
you know do another couple months of
that and just taping
you know riffing on things but there's
the ideas are getting tighter and more
well-formed and
um and you know how it is you have an
ang you have a idea and you have to
sometimes try different angles and i'm
like
i'm too angry when i say that i should
make it more innocent or i should not do
it through my point of view but the
kid's point of view or whatever however
you
come to figure out how to talk about
that thing you want to talk about
and then
like the very end of it as i go to
bigger venues like uh bell house and
uh you know it's just me no guess i go
up i have a real strong idea but then
it's about
sequencing like is this too much
uh
heavy stuff and where is this too much
silly [ __ ] and like how to sprinkle in
the silly [ __ ] when you get you intuit
that feeling of like okay it's time to
move on let's move on let's lighten it
up or let's let's get series or let's do
something anecdotal that they can relate
to or whatever and you know it's a
really important part and then i'll ask
the audience at the end like what do you
all think did you
did you think it was too much i do that
at the end of the the you know the last
phase as it were yeah um
and uh and the audience
who uh came up with the
titles for the last two shows so i did
that's the this one is called i'm from
the future
and um the one before that was called oh
come on
and they're both taken from lines of
things that i say but whenever i
approach
and i'm always wrong always
like hey i had some ideas for the
for the name of the tour the name and
special um and i'll say them and they're
all they're kind of like pompous or just
bullshitty bad puns
people
the ones i like people were like no
that's a bad idea
and then and then with this one and the
one before it people in the audience
were like
shouted it out and i was like oh yeah
that's a cool idea like wasn't my idea
of somebody else's but you did but did
you say i'm from the future like in in
the body of the special you say it yeah
it's it's the bit where i'm talking to
the kids the little kids
uh about what they're going to grow up
to become angry about right and uh and
it's just a little thing
hey
my name's david i'm from the future and
i'm here to tell you and it's very good
uh um um
for people that haven't purchased a
special online that a comedian has put
out himself
how would people go about to find your
special thank you george yes yes it's uh
it'll be on my
website which is called
officialdavidcross.com
and uh i'm doing it that kind of model
that a a bunch of comics louis c.k has
done a number of comics
and you have total control you guys you
go
you buy it and you have it and you can
do whatever you want with it i think
within reason um
and uh
and yeah it's called i'm from the future
officialdavecross.com
and are you paying attention to this
stuff george
okay
we're recording
because you know um
i did a special at show time
but then i was working on my show so i
couldn't edit and then the guy from
showtime did it and when i saw it i
didn't like it yeah i didn't like what
he did i didn't like what he took out
and he took it out because he didn't
like
what which should have been not him
should have been me
yeah was it an exacto
i bump against this
yeah i said well you know it stays well
can we do this but he just you know i
let him well that's the other thing uh
and you're in a much better position to
do this than i am but i mean you just
you do it yourself you have complete
control yeah you know and i shot i mean
the shows i did were probably i did
three three
sets over two nights and they were about
roughly about an hour and 20 25 minutes
and i cut it down to an hour and five
yeah and
and there were some bits that i i was
like you know what i'm going to pull
this because
this can be better and if i go out on
the road this who who knows what this
bit will develop into and um
and it just it's a better process so so
that's that's an accumulation of three
shows
yeah
yeah who edited in
uh i mean when i tell you i scrambled i
had to cancel the tour
and then it was like look i've got a lot
of this material
that
you know who knows when i'm going to be
able to go back out on tour and i've got
this project that is going to start
uh in the spring with with bob owen kirk
and his brother bill and and this could
take a while and you know by time i go
on the road it could be two years around
so
a lot of this material i'm not going to
do that right two years i'm going to do
stuff about my dog in two years and all
that so
i was like i just scrambled to put it
together and uh and did it and the the
great thing about releasing it myself
when i went to go
uh
try to sell it and people were like well
our our slots are filled we couldn't
really air this until
you know summer of 2022 and like well
fine that's way too far so now i sh i
shot it in november and it's going to be
out in a couple months
from november yeah
and anybody who's a fan of comedy it's
just great to have i mean you can just
carry it around you own it yeah you
should really i mean i'm not kidding you
should check into doing it it's a really
good feeling and and it lives in
perpetuity on your space and people can
get it but in the way you started the
special
it
like the way you said in sequencing it
allowed you to do things
in the middle and toward the end
that the audience was already with you
yeah absolutely and things that are
interesting you know the euthanasia of
of a dog
which i had a dog for 16 years
and um that's a long time in a long time
and i gave it to my wife before we got
married
and
he came from champion bloodline wasn't
that expensive but when we went to go
take him to get his shots that the vet
said i hope you didn't pay a lot of
money for this dog this dog's like and
we're like yo mass it's like that's like
a kid to us now you're kidding me what
do you what do you mean but [ __ ] that
bet we're like get in the car we're like
well i got back to that bed
but we took care of this dog
and treated him like family was just
before even before my daughter was born
and he was around he lived his b16 and
he fell into the pool one
one time when he was older and couldn't
get out and the neighbor heard him
yelping and we went and got him and anne
was just inconsolable more than i've
ever seen anybody for a human being yeah
and i said and
you know you got it you got to get a
hold of yourself you know she's holding
him in this towel that she looks up and
i'm just i was like you kind of i mean
it's a dog don't say that you know
and just i was like wow what's good and
i thought to myself what's going to
happen
it's going to be pretty soon because
he's can't get around he's in his hips
were in pain
and that we went to go
take him to get put down and uh
in the car he
was like a puppy looking around open the
windows head is out the window and i
said are you sure that
he didn't have a you know and
he you know you're just like they gather
this strength people do it they gather
the strength
and we went in there
and
man they give him like the half shot i
know man and then
he goes you can say goodbye
and i couldn't take it i was
i was her we changed roles
and i couldn't take it and they're
looking at me and just looking at me
like and i
and i laughed you know and i went in the
car
you're still having a hard time i can
see it right now and and uh
it's awful it's
we went to so we went to a
woman psychic of psychic dog psychic in
marina del rey well that's not a scam
she had a picture of the dog somebody
had fed extra tour he's on his way so
listen so listen let me say let me see
so
uh we go in there and the lady and the
woman says to the
person i took i took i wasn't even there
for me
and gabriel this dog had passed away and
then she said to me you had a dog and i
said yeah i did
and she told me his name
and she said to me
he wants he wants me to tell you you
know
that he understands
and and i said
okay
and she was like did you
did you leave the room
in a time i said oh i left the room
where he was being put down
and she's like he's he wants me to tell
you that he he understands that you love
them and and stuff i don't think
anybody would know that
uh well it's an educated guess
and she asked you the question she
didn't say it as a statement like you
left the room didn't you she said did
you live and probably people uh often
leave the room
um
so
yeah
sorry man cold reading spoilers yeah
well thank you she died as well
she didn't comment did she
show me 1100
and for the and for the crystals in exit
3.
my chesapeake bay retriever was old
arthritis that set in the doc vetted
already told me you know he says you'll
know he's getting older and he's in pain
so finally it was time you know and i
could see i mean just to get up to move
and so i told the wife i said okay it's
time i'm gonna take him to bed how old
was he uh he's probably about 13 then
and he's and my wife said
my daughter and i will go with you and i
said no because all you can do is cry
you guys just stay here i'll take him
so macho dad takes him to the vet
the vet says okay you want to put him up
on the table i put him on the table
you want to stay in here i said
absolutely not and i started crying yeah
i just started crying never cried
and i cried like a baby i walked out and
he said okay come back in back in the
dog he looked like his sleeve his paw in
front of his head right there peaceful
and i left
years i told my wife i don't want
another dog that's it i got too attached
no more dogs
years later
i'm gonna retire and i told the wife i
said i want another dog now i want a
companion it's gonna be different for me
you know i want another dog got the dog
took it back to the bed i said hey doc i
don't know
you used to take care of another dog for
me you're a new dog you know i remember
you you're the very emotional man
cool
i mean you should be i hope you're very
emotional yeah what kind of
weirdos just dropping off a you know
lifelong pet going
all right here you go kill this thing
and uh you guys text me when it's done
you know i'll come and get his ashes uh
toss it out back
after it's not good for me there's
there's stuff that i cut from that from
that bit about
the it's it's really about you know the
the
when it happens and then the next couple
minutes because i i had i had people
come to
uh the house and do it and which i
wasn't know where they did though yeah
that's a that's a thing i didn't know
about it until but i know like as i said
uh you know my sister's done it and i
have friends who've done it and um
you know it's
as you describe they give them the
sedative and then they
you know and i was it was
you know i i i was in such an emotional
state um
as was everybody and uh uh
she the the vet did that classic thing
with the you know they had the
stethoscope and then took it off and you
know she's like um okay she's she's
whatever and i'm stupid i'm like going
so is oh no she goes her heart is
stopped i go so is she dead you know
like i knew i know the answer to that
but i still was like so that's it
yeah it's a big it's big i think they
carry you through your life if you're a
kid and you end up with a dog and the
dog lives
he's carrying you through your your in
your early teens
i understood i did i did not cry and i
understood
when my when my mom passed when they
came in they said hey give her a shot
she paid well you know she won't be able
to talk show me
i don't care it's about her they gave
her the shot she went to sleep and i
didn't even cry then my dog you know dog
gives you
you know love that's all
unconditional love
it's pretty pretty amazing you know and
what you just described as well you know
like
even with
there's there's more of a thing within
with people sometimes you know um yeah
how was your daughter during that your
dad's very young yeah uh she
my wife and i were not uh
expecting nor prepared for
how
hard she took it we didn't think she
would take it that hard and she
she was upset for days and and when that
happened she was four and a half you
know
and uh
we just didn't expect and we had her we
had her do a sleepover somewhere and we
had them come in
that
day was like done in the afternoon and
and also that
the idea you know
it's going to happen and i'm taking my
dog for its last walk and it's last meal
and all because this we didn't have them
come until three o'clock so the whole
all day you're like just looking and
feeling weird it's just weird
yeah and then and then they come in
it's very
uh you know it's calming it's good for
the dog it's better than you know if we
went to the vet she would she knows
and
and so this is this is um
and yeah so then when
my daughter came back the next morning
we'd go hey we have uh um
and we're planning we have a house
upstate and where the whole idea was
like come put her in the car and just
like we're going for the weekend and uh
um you know just get away from where all
this stuff happened and uh
and we said hey so and she knew also we
were preparing her for months and months
and she saw how what condition ollie was
in our dog and um
and we said you know ollie uh
you know got sick last night and passed
away and she [ __ ] lost it and we were
not expecting that it was the whole
write up and just the d you know
um and she would you know
seem fine and then the next day she'd
like i miss ollie
you know it's just it was tough it was
tough and what kind of dog what kind of
dog was it i have no idea i don't know
um
i never saw her i paid him
no she was a rescue dog and um she we
had the the
what do you call the the dna swab thing
done and she
was there was nothing that was 50 or
over but the most prominent
mix was akita and rottweiler but she was
very furry
kind of soft ears very very
uh and about medium size like 55 pounds
have you got another dog
no
and i want to there's a there's
and you know when you have a child it's
a
it's a big well i want to for
you know what that's disingen i was
going to say i want to do it for for our
daughter but
it's actually i want to use my daughter
as an excuse to get another dog because
my wife
my wife would like a cat um and you know
we live in new york and that thing when
you got a when the dogs
got you know got the shits and you it's
four in the morning you're like [ __ ]
god damn it and then you it's snowing
god damn it come on take [ __ ] go poop
that's true that's true
and uh so
the what we had said was we'll wait till
after the winter and when
when it's like spring we'll get because
it'll be a puppy you know and
then and cats
[ __ ] cats hey when they did the dna
[ __ ] cats we had a cat you wouldn't see
that [ __ ] for months yeah to the
house somewhere
i mean it's like where the [ __ ] is this
cat
i mean
nowhere no hair yeah didn't use a litter
box
[ __ ] water store like what the [ __ ]
it was on the house one day
i mean
my daughter's
um
well rottweiler probably yeah well you
know i rescued dogs uh uh and i was not
you know
i didn't know my father or my mother's
awful upbringing
no no no association to anything you
didn't cling to anyone
and uh
we had dogs and things like that i never
really got close to him and then i did
this project and this girl says uh
i said what do you do she goes i rescue
dogs a part of this she's big love
rescue she was in here and she says you
ever watched those videos of those dogs
being rescued or being surrendered or
being abandoned i said no oh god
i wish i hadn't i wake up in the middle
of the night i start watching one where
the people move away and they leave the
dog and it won't let anybody come near
them and then they win them over and it
just turned me into
a rescued dog person which i didn't
expect to be i probably rescued maybe 25
dogs in the last seven that's great we
have we have one now that found us and
started hanging around out nobody could
get near him uh i thought he think who's
coming to your home yeah oh yeah and he
looked like he was rabid he was skinny
he was dirty he was amazing nobody could
get anywhere near him my neighbor and
myself called animal control we didn't
know where this dog was coming from
animal control came by and they left the
little leash said hey you can get close
enough put a leash on him he said we'll
come back and pick him up we can't get
close enough to him
this went on for about a week and i just
started i told my wife i said i can't
let this dog out here
put some water and food out here
so he started coming around and finally
got close enough to him and he'd come
and eat on the floor in front of me and
then i got him to eat out of my hand
and i took off for the dad to go get my
car serviced called the wife up i said
okay
she's not a real animal lover not she's
never been a dog liberty and i said okay
you can call uh the death squad over so
we mean that i said well yeah you know
animal growth is going to come down i
get leash on them they're just going to
take them to kill them they're going to
euthanize them
and
i said that's what you want
so uh just letting you know it'll happen
today
and when i got home about half hour
later there was a stainless steel water
bowl stainless steel dish a bed
you played the long game
that dog knew what you're doing oh yeah
i don't know if it was better for the
dog or better for my family right
and now
uh that that is coming up next month
it'll be a year that we've had the dog
nice and he's just a great dog we're
having a little problem he started
having he had a seizure so i took him
down to the vet matter of fact i was
there with the vet for something else
and he had a seizure while he was there
i said hey seizure time
you know and he's right there they saw
him they gave him some medication how
old is he they think he's it'll be six
now because we're gonna be five
and he's a
terrier mix just a little [ __ ] you know
and he's uh
so they gave him medication and that
made him really lethargic a long time
you know it just
drained him and yeah a neighbor of ours
has a very similar dog
and he said my dog was having a t-shirt
and they gave me some medication made
him really
dopey
and so
we just stopped giving it to him and now
if he still has seizures every once in a
while
and all we did which is the first time
he'd had one around me i just picked him
up and held him just kept held him tight
so he still has uh
still have seizures every once in a
while some are stronger than others but
i don't know what to do you know and
then
i think i think you you know made the
right choice and not giving him you know
not sedating him or yeah
uh
we're happy he's happy
it's all good you know and i think do do
they know they're rescued i believe that
they oh they know they've received a
better life i think so for sure yeah in
in the girl natalie that would help me
we got a i had a dog i said hey go find
a you know i was trying to keep a few in
there there was a spot in the roster
open
and i said hey now go over here and see
if you can find a little dog and see if
there's one you know and she goes over
there she calls me she goes there's not
there's there's not any here
and then i was leaving and they said
there's one in the back
that's in the medical thing but just
because it was older and it would i
called it the chew piece because it
looked like the chupacabra was all
chihuahua that was all kind of beat up
on sideways
and uh i took him and he might he lived
maybe a year
and just was so sweet and and but looked
like he had a heart you know i had an
uncle that was a
that was a hype you know they call it a
drug addict guy and you come around and
he looks so different than everybody
else in the family skinny guns a
different colored skin you're like [ __ ]
that isn't my uncle and that and that
dog learned to i mean
it could walk very slow but he could
still walk
and he would eat would you go put a
sweater on him he was cool you know and
and
the minute that he had trouble standing
up he got mad at himself
like like
i can't stand like and she would say
come and watch this and he would try to
get up and he couldn't do it and you
could see himself almost frustrated with
himself not being able to stand up and
i'd never seen that in a in a dog before
and you know having those dogs i think
you know from growing up the way i was a
little bit detached but then giving and
seeing them
looking helpless and then
whether the freedom walk to the car and
then she would get them something to eat
like a hamburger or something and they
and they look in an hour dave you know
that completely
happy smiling a dog smiles just happy
then when you walk by them and you look
at them like
like they're in the cage and people walk
by and they're trying to engage with
people my wife
i know it hurts on the inside still
because that dog
she takes it she tells me
i feed that dog i take that dog out the
[ __ ] i do everything you know it's cold
outside rainy she goes out there she was
a dog
and
but yet you come around oh yeah and the
dog starts crying he sees me while he
starts crying at the door can't wait to
get he gets here he's all over me
in the morning
open my bedroom door and you can hear
him like a racehorse racing down the
hallway
come and jump up on the bed and then
i'll need to jump up a little bit and
right there next to me says
see
i do everything for him yet
you're the one that he always it was
probably that initial week that you know
you are the savior you're the one who
you know
what's different about living in uh in
new york and brooklyn than living in
atlanta or living in los angeles you
know when you i say and you ride your
bike everywhere which is cool
right you ride your bike a big deal i
mean yeah to be able to ride your bike
somewhere yeah yeah that's that's um i
mean i i just prefer and i you know i
lived in la for
nine and a half years and obviously i
have to come back here when i've gotten
work here um
but i i pref i'm just
my personality type i just prefer
denser
you know i like
being able to walk
a lot and and seeing a lot of different
stuff uh i don't i don't
like the idea of oh i gotta go pick up
some milk and having to get in the car
and do that um
and
i like the
uh
kind of the neighborhood
vibe in uh in new york and um
and i like
there's a different
um
like atlanta is a very
uh people are friendly and um
and that's just kind of a southern thing
people just there's more engagement you
know um a lot of it is kind of chit
chatty stuff but there's just more and
every time i go home
i'm like oh this is a nice way to be you
know um
and
not the people are mean or aloof in la
it just doesn't happen i think the
difference with la
uh
is
for so many people
uh
and this is this is also not good uh if
you're comedian as well but for so many
people's experience
you're in your house which is you know
you got some space or your apartment uh
where you don't see a lot of other
people and then
you get in a car which is you know you
get in this box and you
drive
to this other kind of bigger box and
then you get in it and then you work and
then you get back in that other little
box and you go back to another box and
and in new york
uh i mean just you know i walk my
daughter to school it's three and a half
blocks down the street and um and i
you know i have like five different
locals i go to where i know all the
bartenders and i know the people there
and and you just know you're
you know yeah you're i i
know the butchers and i know i just you
just know people
and and you experience more
in a
you know day-to-day basis i think more
interaction with other people and seeing
different things and uh you know right
in the subway which is one of my
favorite things i love the subway and
and riding my bike and uh right
and so that that difference i guess is
the biggest if somebody wasn't um a
person you know like me like i've lived
out here my whole life and if i spend
some time over there do you think does
someone adapt to that lifestyle like to
be able to walk to a store sure you'll
be able to walk to something and it kind
of opens you up where you didn't think
like i wouldn't think that i would enjoy
that but if i was there i'm sure i would
well this it's not like walking in the
store here it's literally you're going
but you also are seeing so many things
in it's not like you're walking through
a residential street but like having
your places that you go have a drink
those guys know you go and you work a
little bit they're cool like hey what's
up you're in there yeah back up your
stuff you go you can walk back home and
be cool yeah yeah i think that's great
oh yeah yeah and also
i
uh
i like four seasons too i like four
distinct seasons i like winter i like
you know i know like a ton of winter but
i like three months of it yeah you know
and i like spring and i like summer and
i like fall yeah and uh and i
you know again i don't like
six months of summer but uh you know
it's it's that feeling especially when
it's like shitty hot out you're in the
heat wave you're like okay i'm i'm ready
for fall
and it falls great yeah you know it's
like it's cooling down and just it's a
different energy and now i got a sweater
and and um and and there and then you
know you get in the winter and and
you're like yeah it's snowing all right
yay and uh and then right at the end of
winter i felt this when i was living in
boston too like really right about the
time we're like all right i'm [ __ ]
over the winter and then it warms up
again right and then you get spring and
spring's really optimistic and it's cool
and people are you're shedding your
clothes and you're like and then summer
oh [ __ ] and all the concerts out at the
you know the the and we we've got
beautiful parts
i'm
you know uh maybe 15 minute walk from
even less from prospect park which has a
zoo which you know i take my kid there
and has uh um
in the next of the botanical gardens and
uh i mean it is it's
it's amazing that it's set up like that
for people to live but not and not here
like over here on the five i mean
growing up here the five freeway was two
lanes on one side
and two lanes on the other no no diamond
lane
no
we traveled more than two people
and
i don't know the engineering but the
five freeway all the way down to san
diego now it's like five lanes on one
side and five on the other
more cars faster
[ __ ] dangerous you know i went down
to san diego on monday on the way back
everybody's going not like 90.
that [ __ ] 90 in and out of [ __ ]
traffic and you said what the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ] but the way they've
found land to go even bigger is is
beyond me bigger but yet there's a place
on the corner when we come here that's
an italian place and i've thought about
going in there to get something to eat
on the way home because it's open he
said let's see if i go in there because
it would be
unusual for me to stop somewhere and eat
before going home but but it's funny i
would i would do that
and maybe do it on a regular basis you
know and not be so much in the box to
the box and then back everything sounds
so beautiful and vital to me that's
exactly where i'd like flip with the
exception of
the winner you know i'm not uh yeah some
people aren't i haven't read that that
book you know famous mexican snow skiers
[Laughter]
mexicans
it's cold as [ __ ] dude
you have a dog [ __ ]
in the morning that's that's a bummer
but i i'm telling you and it sounds like
i'm
making some uh some you know lefty
statement but i'm not but the winters
are not nearly as harsh anymore because
the climate change global warming i mean
it just isn't you know it it is not
you know
it used to be when i was when i was
younger
and
you know because i spent some time in
new york when i was a kid too and
like you would have
set like snow days and now you just get
a couple of
you know you get a couple of storms
every once in a while and can you look
up that i think that
they maybe china created an artificial
sun
they released an artificial sun what are
you talking about damned you mean up in
the air sun what are you talking about
yeah like oh [ __ ] okay
somebody told me yesterday china's one
so they launched an artificial sun into
the sky
china's one trillion dollar artificial
sun fusion reactor just got five times
hotter than the sun it's five times
hotter than this wait on but it's the
reactor is on it looks like it's an
earthbound reactor
i haven't seen it i haven't seen it
either so this is so how do you get near
it
how do you how do you get close enough
to shut it off it's that
you know that assembly of pipes and
fancy looking [ __ ] that went into the
air uh it doesn't i can't see that so
far i think it's just it just warms up
the one house on the block they just
heated the [ __ ] out of it yeah that's a
man they're making artificial [ __ ]
suns
a trillion dollar sun that's five times
hotter than the sun
how was it five times hotter than the
sun how do you even
you know what that burned the [ __ ] out
yeah i
this feels like yeah we'd feel here yeah
yeah so um i feel like this and who is
it
can we not be warmed by that 150 million
degrees fahrenheit 158 million degrees
fahrenheit
so
that's just for s'mores
i mean ultimately the plan with the
fusion reactors is for it to be like a
source of energy yeah um
it's just very inefficient right now
even if you can make [ __ ] super hot i'll
bust through this see if they're going
through trial and error
unplug it
but i mean you know i i think you know
with uh with um
global warming everything you know
nobody really wants to believe that this
[ __ ] is happening
that will be gone by the time it affects
us really but it's affecting us every
day growing up here oh yeah it rained
when i was in elementary school it
rained the whole month of february which
it used to rain you could tell when it
was going to come and rain it stopped
raining
and it rained the whole month of
february
and it rained you know you're from here
and it hasn't
it doesn't rain hardly anymore yeah
i can't remember that far back
[ __ ]
i don't know
didn't that didn't even have a rain
jacket but we were just poor mexican go
out there and what you had yeah i always
pretend i left it at home
my wife is from uh
uh born and raised uh santa monica
venice santa monica and uh
and it took um
i'd say three or four years for her to
get comfortable with the cult now she's
great about it um but uh
then the other extreme is
you know
and i know so many people from santa
monica again born and raised right
and they're
they're um
their spectrum i guess of uh where
they're comfortable i just feel sorry
for them because like anything below
60 is
three
yeah and anything above 80 is like oh
it's [ __ ] broiling yeah and it's like
it's and i you know growing up in
georgia and also northeast and living in
in
boston new york like i'm i'm
i'm pretty copacetic with a large swing
um
i just feel bad for those they're just
spoiled from santa monica
bother me at all i like the wig no they
are they are they i mean and i lived in
uh uh when i was shooting arrested
development i i
uh
for the first time lived on the west
side because when i was living in la i
always lived on the east side i was only
in los fels or silver lake the entire
time i was here
and then
and i don't like santa monica or venice
but the weather is [ __ ] awesome it's
amazing
i mean when it's 95 degrees out here you
know an eagle rock or whatever and then
you're like huh so it's just like
pocket that the breeze comes in yeah and
the sun is different
uh i'm a member of the golf club over
here
and in the summer when it gets hot at
three o'clock every day there's a breeze
that comes through every day at three
o'clock
i don't think it's from that but
it's almost like in routine three
anything after three o'clock it cools
down considerably but before that no
breeze still
and then it just it just cools off
i'm just fascinated with what david
calls the east side
you know
yeah
they're not going over there yeah
come to my east side no true good point
fair point but it's you know
all of that thing has changed like
venice was a big you know artsy back
then you know the people that were out
there but you know
with the homelessness in in this area
it's bad oh my god it's like it's never
been so so a proposal from someone that
you know in law enforcement was to
get all of the abandoned hospitals and
abandoned places that they have in this
which which is more than enough space to
take care of of the homeless situation
but because in city council every city
has its own police force they have their
own laws it's hard to get
the city of los angeles and all the
council people to agree to say right and
l.a is huge i mean it's huge
and they they won't agree
to allow them
the the problem isn't just
you know homelessness per se it's mental
illness there's a lot of and uh and my
wife had a place uh you know when and i
would was there on on uh fourth and rows
so um
uh i mean it was
you couldn't escape it was everywhere
and it wasn't just oh these people are
down luck these are people are severely
mentally ill and they need help
you know and and it's not just about
you know oh let's
you know let's we'll put them in this
we'll put them in this uh place we'll
turn this into a you know these they
need more than
walls and a ceiling i mean yeah
and uh um
so if we're like if it's that way so
compartmentalized by cities and by
districts and and things that they will
never agree to i mean just in itself the
los angeles the general hospital sits
empty and that thing is massive yeah you
know massive but you're right it should
be you it should be used you know
all those things that are gone but also
um that i've lived here my whole life
and i've never seen homeless people
be violent to people on the street and
in the last two years
i've seen it i've seen it a lot it's
ugly and it's not and
you know just out of nowhere a guy with
a pipe and the kids and the mom they're
waiting for the bus and that that should
be enough to be able to throw the red
flag up to say that's happening in new
york too where uh new york for i mean i
think it still remains this way but i
think it's creeping the other way but
it was the safest big city in america
and
and uh
but in the last
year or so i mean there have been a lot
of this you know this pushing people in
front of this up [ __ ] from the 70s oh
yes
that's like 70s [ __ ]
and uh there's some people in front of
the subway and it's meant they're
mentally ill these are people these are
people
are mentally ill they're not like
homicidal by nature you know yeah and
it's
yeah things are tragic yeah tragic um
are are you do you consider yourself you
know arrested development amazing troy
miller everybody there yeah you know
when the show that's a show that needed
to continue when a lot of shows that
you
my daughter's number one show oh it's
incredible what was that i mean you had
some amazing amazing amazing cats yeah
the
it was it was it was just such a treat
and um
and as you said the cast was was there
an improv side of it or was it were was
it pretty much what was written it was
uh almost all of what was written and uh
and we used to say because people would
ask us ask us that a lot and
honestly outside of the the pilot and
maybe
the first half of the first season
um
[Music]
you know a couple times you'd rift
something just because it's just by
nature especially when you're you know
you're on your fourth take or fifth take
or whatever and um
but the scripts were so dense and then
we're cut down that uh i mean it and it
feels like it's improvised that's that's
a testament to how strong the writing
was
you know and it really wasn't you know
there were a handful of things here and
there but
not
not not as many as people
think
it's uh maybe one of the most underrated
shows and when people talk about the
best shows on tv and you know as as time
goes you know other shows come that may
not be as good but you know it's like a
pecking order but that arrest
development was
incredible oh yeah especially that
original run is like that's on the mount
rushmore
yeah those first three seasons were were
and we knew it was special too i in fact
i was initially
um
they wanted me to to look at
buster and job and i did not have a
handle on job at all and um
and i and i just moved to new york and i
after being in la for nine nine years of
going like i gotta get the [ __ ] out of
here and uh finally found an opportunity
and then and i was having the time of my
wife and um
uh
book a trip book a job right
and and then i get the script and like
uh
i i wasn't that interested but and and
they said just read it and i did not
connect with job at all i had no handle
on that
and then
but when i was reading tobias i was like
oh i knew instantly who that guy was
like i know and i was really attracted
to it because it was like oh part time i
can just come in and out i don't have to
move back to la and do like six episodes
that was great and then
uh
came out to shoot the pilot
and i remember this i will never forget
it it was at the
beverly connection which is across from
beverly center and there's there was a
place called soup plantation
and they had the walkway in the back and
it was on the and i called
my girlfriend in new york
[Music]
and i
said to her listen this
this show is gonna be very good it's
very special and uh i think i need to do
this on a regular basis and uh and you
know we had been we kind of were in a
newer relationship and she didn't you
know get in you know
sign up for having to move to l.a or not
or having a boyfriend that wasn't going
to be there for
five months a year so um but i was like
this is it's too good i got i got a
really strong this is just shooting the
pilot i don't think that there would
have been a thing that would have
stopped you creatively i think
creatively you you felt like this is
something that i should do you talk to
your girlfriend and say that you know i
kind of i like this a lot of times
people make decisions where a woman is
involved and they may
not do it because of that person yeah
well that's i mean i was telling her i
wasn't asking
but i mean that's how strong i mean it
was a
uh
and i fought at tooth and nail i did not
want to go back to la i had only been in
new york at that point for what a year
and
change and uh maybe whatever it was two
years and
and again i was having so much fun and
uh
so much [ __ ] george yes
just ridiculous
i mean
anyway um no i mean and and i was like i
just knew we knew from shooting it's all
different too it's not this even though
it looks the same it's all it's all
different you talk about the [ __ ]
it comes in the same container
um one of a kind god bless you guys it's
not one of a kind it's kind of
kind of a one
[Laughter]
yeah it was it was it was great it was a
and a great cast did you have your youth
rolled in or
no no i didn't i started i started
thinning out
when i was like 19. oh
yeah yeah about 19 and i still have i
had like kind of uh
i just let my hair grow especially like
out of high school and becoming you know
your own person independent individual
um and i grew my hair out and i was high
all the time and i had my horn rib
glasses with tape on them because i
couldn't afford to fix them and
um
and
but it started thinning out and i was i
mean i was like this kind of ball
by the time i was i mean really when i
was doing mr show you know it was and
and that was
i mean i was
uh 30. so i was i was bald bald by
27 i'd say it went pretty quickly maybe
even earlier
did you
would you prefer to have kept it or is
it i mean you know no well uh or did it
not matter like
it didn't matter uh i don't know if you
recall the last uh uh what we were just
talking about but um
it didn't it didn't matter
and then i can wear wigs easily and like
really change up my especially for
something like mr show where you're
doing all these characters and bits and
stuff and i could
you know i'm i come out and i'm bald and
uh and then you throw in a wig and take
the glasses off and i i'm like a totally
different guy you know which is helpful
if you're doing that kind of thing was a
great show too oh also on the on the
sketch mount rushmore
i'm
i'm in two of them
i believe that you and i have something
in common i believe we both lost a weird
l for a grammy
[Laughter]
i never lost to a [ __ ] comedian
well i say that now [ __ ] wins them
i get i get nominated the grammys i'm in
pebble beach i make the cut they're like
are you gonna go to the grammys i said i
don't know i mean then somebody gets on
the phone listen man where the hell wins
every time
he's won six already if you're in the
lead or near the lead just stay over
there we'll let you know [ __ ] call
never came
oh listen listen i say i i don't know if
you know al he's the nicest sweetest guy
i love him what does his mantle look
like
yeah 12 [ __ ] grammy's up there
yeah but i mean
i think it's a different it's almost
i mean i just feel like it's not
it's a different category i feel like it
it's it's
doing stand-up comedy is that different
but it goes into
i
i lost to colbert who did a special on
comedy central which is different that's
almost like a variety
and then i lost to flight of the
concords that was music and comedy but
never lost to a comedian
right right i lost to
people that were other but that's what
i'm saying i wish it was a its own
category because it's a it's a different
thing and they're
they're all deserving of
of notice and uh um
and uh you know everything we've
mentioned they they're they're all
deserving but it is
different to write a
a 60-minute monologue that has uh that
has such a different craft and different
skill set to it um
than to do you know to write
uh song parodies or to do a variety show
or i mean it could be edited down to
half an hour it's a half hour christmas
special that was edited down but i agree
i agree with you completely well there's
a a
while we're talking about this one thing
that always bothered me was
[Music]
when uh mr show got
nominated for a handful of emmys and
uh one
the the
the the year that we did like i think
was uh season three or four was uh was
like kind of our big year and uh i think
we got nominated for three three emmys
and um
[Music]
there was comedy the the best
performance best
comic performance by mail or whatever
and
in the
show that we submitted
um
it was it was the one that had a sketch
called prenatal pageants which i think
is some of
it's it's one of bob's bob owen kirk's
uh best performances
and you can see
the
you can see how he's
would become the the great dramatic
actor he's become and it's just a really
he's just it's a funny sketch and it's a
funny idea but he's [ __ ] great in it
he's and he's it's
real it's grounded it's it's it and
there's pathos to it and he just does
all this stuff with his character in
this five-minute sketch
and
the the award for best comic performance
went to dennis miller
who
had a talk show and uh
uh you know there was like a monologue
in the beginning
and and then there was like a sit down
and you talked to people and then there
was like um it was like photo funnies or
something like that and that like you're
going to tell me that performance was
better than what bob did in the entire
episode where he did all these different
things
and he wasn't recognized at all it's
always been like a um and this isn't
necessarily a knock against dennis
miller per se it's the thing it's the
the the
the thing that you're doing is that's
not even close to what bothers me it's
not i think has it changed in the last
few years where there is more spoken
but then you shouldn't be i mean i don't
have a spoken word entitled but it
should be for stand-up comedy yeah we're
talking about two different things we're
talking about emmys versus grammys but i
i think for both of them they need to be
there needs to be a distinction right
because right as you know as you well
know
i mean doing putting together from
scratch a 60-minute set going out there
refining it sequencing it editing it
how do you perform it um
[Music]
is vastly different than those other
things right
and it's harder to
be harder i think it's harder
you're sitting at a desk you're going
through the news and then you're
creating a character with the story and
the writing and
you know great seasons
and hbo at that time powerhouse
hbo comedy especially yeah yeah yep yep
uh yeah it looks like now broken up into
a couple categories um oh they just
disappeared but there's nothing you
wanted me for
uh ben stoller show yeah writing and we
we won i think we won an emmy for
i thought we won for music on mr show
i'm not sure
uh
i know we were nominated for like we had
a year where we were nominated for like
three emmys but um
i i don't yeah i don't remember it's
good to see you man you've done
incredible work well thanks and thanks
for coming to uh to visit us yeah
absolutely and uh eye opener for me all
right i'm ready to move to new york okay
we wait wait till uh wait till the
winter till march
but yeah and uh
well thank you very much
yeah and this will be on probably a week
and a half if you want to tell people uh
again just want to check it out oh yes
so the the special is called i'm from
david cross i'm from the future
and you can get it uh at my website
officialdavidcross.com it'll be
available on february 12th is the
live stream premiere thing but you can
get it and then you can have it
and do with it what you will
check it out
awesome all right man
you